brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available on consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29 if
it's Thanksgiving time in your part of
the world then there are plenty of games
to be thankful for even better all this
week's games are launching on the same
day which could make for a rockin
Thanksgiving dinner if the family gets a
few drinks in them then it's the perfect
time to break out we sing it the karaoke
game originally launched on the Wii in
2009 but now it's coming to ps4 and xbox
one with 30 new songs and music videos
the tracks cover all sorts of genres and
time periods so there's something for
everybody here from ABBA to Britney
Spears to Wiz Khalifa you can start
flexing the golden pipes on Tuesday
November 22nd if you'd rather scream
than sing then the amnesia collection is
right up your alley the amnesia series
has been scaring PC gamers for years but
this trio of games is getting repackaged
for ps4 the collection includes amnesia
the dark descent a machine for pigs and
Justine a spin-off that takes cues for
more claustrophobic movies like saw you
can pick up the collection on the 22nd
if you dare as for games at the kiddie
table dragonball fusions is coming to
the west new characters taka and pin
achar thrust into the world of
dragonball exploring different times and
planets as they collect and fuse fan
favorite characters like Goku and
piccolo and trunks the whole game is
painted in a cutie chibi art style so
your custom fused characters will be but
powerful and adorable you can start your
collection on the 22nd it might not be
in the spirit of giving thanks but the
horsemen war is returning to Earth and
darksiders war mastered addition he's
still on a quest to restore balance
after a premature apocalypse but this
time he'll do it with improved graphics
and frame rates if you're playing on PC
you'll be able to kick that even higher
with four case
abort and did I mention it's only 20
bucks just like the other games on this
list you can dig in on the 22nd and
after all that turkey and stuffing it's
time to get up and move with hollow ball
think racquetball meets Tron the HTC
vive game is making its way to
PlayStation VR so you'll be able to nail
all those fancy trick shots with move
controllers don't forget to fasten those
wrist straps you'll also be able to take
on your friends and local multiplayer
and no surprise here you can start
serving on the 22nd and those are the
games will be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll see you next week
Oh